hi everyone it's Jerry let's have a look
at a game that was played at the 2005
Linares tournament on the white end
Michael Adams and he's playing against
Gary kosparov
this is a nice Dynamic game open
Sicilian night orb
English attack
this is a 26 move game
we're going to have on board a raised
position in opposite sides Castle's
position
in these opposite sides Castle's
positions I think some of the better
moves you'll find are ones that combine
both attack with defense
we're going to see at least a couple
instances of this by kasprov in this
game and I think it's these very moves
that go a long way towards his attack
arriving first
all right we continue with E6 black has
a small Pawn Center
Bishop E2
Queen C7 an important move
Queen C7 this move I should say it
should precede B5 if you're running in
with B5 too soon
Bishop F3 and black would experience a
problem along this diagonal
so first queen C7 and only after
the queen is on C7 do we have B5 Bishop
F3 in this case no problems Bishop B7
the bishop is defended the diagonal is
secure
okay white secures the Knight post
black increases the pressure on e4
that's defended now where do we go from
here move 10 Can you spot kasprov's next
move
feel free to pause the video
okay he goes with
Knight C6
black already has an ion what exactly a
pawn break
black nose white is going Queen side
that is the idea with this English
attack
to Castle Queen side and then launch the
G and H pawns attacking the Knight along
the way and in the end creating contact
with G6 creating this Fork idea and by
hitting with G6
some file will be cracked open for white
Rook
okay
continuing we have Queen side castles
and black gets on with it straight away
B4
there's a way you could go wrong there's
black right here might be attempting
move Rook C8 is a way to
uh go wrong seems logical enough half
open file opposite the king but
you have to be aware of this tactic by
why
you give up the minor piece and get
these three Pawns
this is an excellent position for white
so
B4 on board it would not be the same now
you're not capturing a pawn when you go
to B5 plus black right around the corner
is ready to
smash open White's King side with B
takes a
okay in this game a takes B Knight takes
B
black has
an open file more than one open file
towards the king
white still needs to work to get that
open file so
here we go G4
Bishop B7 G5 only one option for the
Knight
in this game it goes to D7 that's best
if you go to the edge you're asking for
F4 there's a problem there
so Knight D7
H4
what is Black's next move here I wonder
if you can spot it feel free to pause
the video okay instructive moment right
here I feel
his move is Knight C5 so at the start
when I was talking about moves that
combine both attack and defense this is
one of the moves I had in mind
Knight C5 in what way is a combining
attack with the defense well
there's two different checks
available I'm not saying either of them
are good right now but it's an
aggressive move it has some offense
offensive ideas
it also coordinates with the Knight on
B4 there might be something fancy
happening on the D3 Square in some cases
in what way does it fulfill a defensive
role by going to C5
it watches over E6
it
tames in a way the Knight on D4 black
knows that this idea is coming and E6 is
going to soon be undermined so there's a
piece now there supporting E6
additionally it prevents some idea of
maybe white inviting the F Pawn into the
mix
whether it is on F6 or C5 there would be
two pieces on e4 so it's interfering
with this idea by white
one of the ways I've gone wrong in a
similar position to this one is to
improve the Knight by going to E5 or B6
with the idea to hop into the C4 Square
normally it's a very appealing Square
for the Knight to go to
let's see why that's bad let's say black
goes for this plan
uh let's say King B1 Knight C4 takes
takes what's the big problem well this
is hitting
these two look invasive but there isn't
any other black piece involved right now
and this is hitting really really fast
and this queen is soon going to have to
be the one to babysit E6 that's not a
good rule for the queen to have
so this is an excellent position for
white
black has to take this idea into account
and does so on this move 15. important
defensive role watching over E6
okay from here King B1
gets out of any Knight checks King goes
to a light Square Knights are on dark
there's no checks by the knights
all right from here Rook B8
the King was out of the PIN
uh with King to B1 is getting out of the
pin on the C file but now black is
saying hang on this Pawn however in
direct is now
pinned
okay in comes H5
White Castles
in G6
so another Pop Quiz what move would you
play in this position as black things
are definitely heating up now tension on
board what do you do
okay
the move played in the game is best
Bishop F6
this takes advantage of the weakness you
could say of black of a White's last
move
F6 is no longer under control and like
this Knight C5 move this is the other
one that combines both attack with
defense clearly
it's on the main diagonal coordinating
really well however indirect on that B2
Square the heart of White's King side
what defensive role does it have well if
this G file opens up
and it seems quite likely that it will
it's there to watch over G7
now
why is this
move right here considered best we could
consider a different move
such as Bishop to AA
in order for this Rook to see the world
what's the problem here well
H6 can hit creating even more tension on
the black side on the black king side
and black is not in time to make the
following moves after takes on G6 takes
on G7 this bishop is not in a position
to recapture on G7 and it wants to be in
position to recapture on G7
King takes is no good in this position
you're asking for trouble Bishop H6
so this moment here move 18 Bishop F6 is
taking into account this idea of H6 if
H6 is played here black can take on G6
with the F Pawn opening up major pieces
to help defend along the seventh rank if
need be and if white takes on G7 black
simply goes back like this things are
cool in fact this Rook has been helped
out with this Pawn sacrifice idea by
white
so
Bishop F6 on this move 18.
Rook on D to G1
now Bishop to A8 getting out of the
Bishops or the Rooks way
Bishop G5 so this is where it's already
pretty tricky for white to come up with
a best move
um
computer likes this one and Rook to G4
but
after the reply Bishop to E5 in this
game the suggestion by the engine as
best is for the bishop to go back where
it came from
so you're really not making a whole lot
of progress playing in this way as white
what is considered best for white
instead of this move is Rook to G4 now
this is a
uh this is definitely a computer-ish
line that I'm going to be highlighting
here
best play if Rook G4 is played is D5 you
ready for this I did not see this one
coming at all when that move was being
suggested
after D5 E5
Bishop takes pawn and you're ready
Knight D to B5
okay when this move was played my mind
was only on oh you're ready to Simply
form a battery and do something on G7
no we're seeing a case where this Rook
can have some lateral influence
anyhow that's that's definitely a tough
one to come up with and again there's no
guarantee black has to go with a move
like D5 but
anyhow computer line to be sure
in this game Bishop G5
seems
yeah this is definitely the more human
move to go with because this guy right
here I would probably assess to be the
the best piece in the game
uh on the main diagonal pointing at B2
coordinating with the Rook
it needs to be tamed
so black recognizes this bishop is way
too good let's not exchange Bishop B5
and from here white captures on H7
so
what do you do here my first thought was
you hide behind the pawn but you could
actually take the pawn
that's what black plays because they're
still this guy you can hide behind
so if H6 here
black would make sure the H file does
not open he'd go with G6
in this game the Knight goes back to B3
black has a winning position here
there's it's actually quite difficult to
even suggest a good move
for white here for example if you try to
get rid of this bishop you're going to
lose a piece instead of the move playing
in the game Knight B3 if you try this
one
black could take the Knight and then
land a fork so
if Bishop to E3
you could play Queen to B6 and now this
Knight is ready to move and there's
going to be mate in one thread on B2 so
what do you do in this game white is
trying to neutralize the pressure along
this B file but now runs into this
tactic Knight takes C2
undermines the support of the B3 Knight
Knight takes Knight follows
and black says you're gonna have to work
a little bit harder to track down my
knight because now this Pawn is
officially pinned so he flicks in first
Knight A3 check
King A2 only now picks up the Knight
and what do you do from here in the game
Knight A4 is played if you're capturing
the Knight we're just exchanging Knights
the queen has hit in comes Rook B2 this
is over for white
in this game Knight A4
and can you spot kasparov's 25th move
feel free to pause the video
okay very flashy and best
Knight C2 very very pretty move Knight
C2 this cuts off one of the two
Defenders
of B2 the queen isn't seeing B2 now and
black is saying if you want to take my
queen you have no defense of B2
and you'll get mated
so
what do you do here in the game King B1
is played
final move of this one
Queen A3
white resigns
taking advantage yet again of the pinned
B2 Pawn B2
is now hit for a third time and there's
just no defense
so you could try maybe Queen takes
Knight
but after Rook F to C8
what do you do as white
if you block with the bishop here the
queen would be overloaded
you could take the bishop and then after
Rook takes B2
it's going to be mate soon enough
any other try in this position let's say
queen D2
black could take a timeout to Simply get
the piece back black is in this position
up a pawn but still this attack is
present B2 is a CL B2 is collapsing this
one is officially over in this position
so
this one goes no further after Queen A3
white simply throws in the towel so
anyhow Feel Free as usual to leave any
feedback to this video in the comments
section below I hope you enjoyed it
maybe took a thing or two away
that's all for now take care bye